thanks for introduction yeah but there
there's going to be one a mathematical
equation actually so i'm mateus a raffle
set and i'm machine learning exactly
that net guru yeah and today i'm going
to talk about reproducible machine
learning so how we can make machine
learning career producible
and let's start with the first slide
which is actually was supposed to be
different but yesterday I attended some
webinar and I got inspired so so I
attended a webinar about stick
prediction and the one thing I noticed
is because basically its standard
Jupiter notebook with loading data but
there's one thing I notice do you see
something louder yeah
untitled so I'm title 16 so if you ever
committed on title 16 alright I told X
notebook to github repository please
raise your hand yeah I did so we can see
on this example that's even if small
things like naming notebooks we are we
don't bother about naming so how we can
bother about actually making sure that
the results we obtain in those notebooks
are actually reproducible but before we
talk about how we make machine learning
reproducible let's start with some
definitions so what is reproducibility
so I define actually the authors of the
paper define and I define the stock
reproducibility as an ability to
reproduce some findings using the same
procedures and same data so basically in
machine learning case we have probably
do karai's environment we have some code
base and some data and we were able to
to run everything in the same different
environment
same code base with same data and obtain
same results and
we have also same hardware for this the
other concept which is similar might be
confusing to reproducibility but it's
different it's replicability so the
difference here is we want to apply the
procedures from from different study to
different data and we want to obtain
similar results so it's something like
we do image classification with some new
Arnett architecture and we test whether
this architecture improves state of the
art on several data sets or other case
would be deep key learning working on
seven Atari games and the first thing is
generalizability this difficult work and
the whole idea of general lizziboo ET
it's about making the concepts
transferring to different domains so
some in my mind example is for attention
layer which works in NLP and and works
in computer vision but and engineers
ability is something that we want to aim
in research but we already have problems
with reproducibility so some time ago
nature conducted the survey asking
scientists do they think that there is a
reproducibility crisis in machine in in
science in general and almost 90 percent
or exactly 90 percent yeah scientists
think that there is and more than 50
percent think that this is huge crisis
but it's not the most horrific fact here
because they ask actually the follow-up
question something's wrong ok yeah so
they ask follow-up question have you
failed to reproduce your experiments or
someone else and the recur if 'ok fact
is like
for each of subfields we have more than
50% people saying that they fail to
reproduce their own research so it's for
me it's crazy because how the research
might be of any significance if we can't
actually reproduce it even our own
research so I don't have better words to
describe the situation that this is
basically madness and now I have a
question is it that bad in machine
learning so Julian Pinot who gave a
great talk at icy air in 2018 about
reproducibility in reinforcement
learning conducted a survey on on some
workshop she conducted between machine
learning engineers machine learning
researchers and the findings are similar
most of machinery engineers said that
there is significant reproducibility
crisis also in machine learning and is
it actually true and I'd say yes because
if you are come on ready to visit or you
can read a lot of things that some
people are trying to reproduce results
of papers or and and there is always
this question how this paper can be even
validated if there is lacking data and
code and probably you had often that
situation that you went to some github
repository that is supposed to solve
your problem and it actually doesn't or
the metrics that are reported to you
always achieving them lower or or you
just can't run the code but is it just
the case for for some researchers who
just posting the github papers and they
are not maybe on the best conferences
actually it's not and there is that
paper from nature about alphago so
probably of all of you heard about
alphago and alpha zero beating release
at all who was world champion and go and
actually that paper has as of yesterday
more than 6,300 citations and actually
there is no data there is no code there
is no details about happy hyper
parameters or complex computational
resources or even evaluation setup so we
have that paper which was cited for more
than 6,000 times about probably one of
the most famous machinery Calgary's
right now and when it's when it was
published it was completely not
reproducible in any way by other
researchers who are not from deep-lined
but it's not the problem which actually
exists only now because some of you
might know the last Fermat's theorem so
the theorems was that no three positive
integers a B and C satisfy the equation
eight to the power of n plus B to the
power of n equals C to the power of n
for any integer value greater than two
and Fermat apparently wrote on on the
margin that the proof is surprising
interesting but there is not enough
space on the margin to to fit the proof
and it took only three hundred fifty
eight years to prove the proof to
publish a proof so so the problem it's
not only now it was much earlier in the
science but what are the specific
reasons for machine learning that we
have some so many difficulties with
achieving reproducibility so the first
one quite trivial machine learning is
very fast evolving everyone who follows
machine learning knows it every Monday
morning when you just check your machine
learning news letters you read about new
genera Tiff's adversarial Network the
second thing is that research is funded
all usually by groups of commercial
interest so they don't release a model
or they don't release the training
details or they don't read it and the
data or does they don't release anything
the usual problem
research communities data dredging and
the problem I want to talk about today
more is that we lack mo ops culture so
basically Devils culture in machine
learning community so we don't do data
versioning and we don't manage our
experiments in your participant manner
so this is typical machine learning
pipeline so we have data engineering
phase then we have some training then we
do deployment and we go back again to
data engineering training and basically
we iteratively building models and once
we go one through that loop it's one
experiment and everything should be
actually stored all information about
that experiment so we can reproduce it
so information like what was the Python
version
what were the versions of libraries so
maybe the docker image what matrix we
achieved what was the seat for random
number generator and so on but one does
not simply remember those experiments so
now I would tell you a story from not so
much a long time ago when I run
experiments on neural networks that were
supposed to memorize the data so there
was this paper like three four years ago
by issue a banjo with that surprising
fact that if you train your neural
networks for long enough on completely
random labels you can achieve 100%
training accuracy with ten percent with
with random so for c4 with ten classes
for example ten percent accuracy on the
test set so basically random so neural
networks are able to fit completely
random labels and I was reproducing that
experiment and I wanted to make sure
later that I know the sequence of the
randomized labels so I basically
randomized them once and I saw that in
file which then at some point I delete
so I wasn't able ready to reproduce the
results because I didn't sort that
information somewhere in the cloud and
in some in some maybe in some tool
that's attracts that so let's carry on
and so the combination of machine
learning and DevOps so it's called mo
ops and basically it's practice of
aperture operationalizing and managing
the lifecycle of mo system in production
and what is the goal of DevOps so the
DevOps started I think in 2009 and at
the time Jess Campbell coined the term
continuous delivery and continuous
delivery is the ability to get changes
of all types into production safely and
quickly and in a sustainable way and
what kind of changes do we have in
machine learning so the first change is
code so it's the same like in standard
software engineering we change the code
according to their business requirements
we change the code when we need to fix
some bugs but what are the other things
that change within machine learning so
the first thing is data and the other
and the other is model so the data might
have different schema after some time
the data distribution might change over
time and the data volume might change
over time and with models we might try
different algorithmic might change the
versions of libraries might change so
for example in PI torch 1.1 butter term
was initialized from uniform
distribution in fighters 1.3 its units
realized as a vector of ones and makes
huge difference in training and it's
easy to to just omit so we need some
tools to to manage those changes in data
and in model so the first thing I'm
going to talk is how we address changes
in data how we do data management
and here I have some quotes from paper
actually that if data replaces code in
our most systems and code should be
tested then it seems clear that some
amount of testing of input data is
critical to a well-functioning system
and basic sanity checks are useful as
more sophisticated tests that monitor
changes in input distributions so if we
test code we should dentists also our
data and in software engineering we have
some principles about managing changes
in code so the first one is we use git
or different version control systems but
probably all of you uses git we have
clean an explicit interfaces between
services so there are those there are
those patterns of micro-services for
example we unit tests and integration
tests our modules and we monitor our
code how it behaves on production and we
might have the same we might have
equivalents of that data engineering so
data managing so the data should be
version so so we somehow we need to know
on what kind of data exactly
somebody was trained on what kind of
data it was tested the other thing is we
need clean interfaces between data and
code so preferably we have just some
class in the code that we can access
data and it's not like we implement over
and over again some loading of the data
from from the directory or from some
cloud storage we should have some data
quality and scheme metrics and we should
check check whether we don't have data
regression over time especially if we
have some system in a production and
those things we address at not grow of
killed which is basically interface to
as free storage but it's going to
support in near future also GCP buckets
so kilts allows us to share data at
scale
it it is basically interface to its free
which is connected to elasticsearch so
data is searchable through elastic
search and it provides notable versions
of data sets which is very important for
doing machine learning and it allows
also to broadens our access to data
within an organization so let's look at
example of kilt how we can use killed so
it's very simple basically so we import
killed then we create the package of
killed so we can set the path to the to
the local directory and we can then we
can also set some metadata here and
basically we push our packages with push
function on the code on the package to
the S Cloud storage so so the code is
very simple it's basically interface to
as free but it allows us to do version
data and to in easy simple form to
address that changes in data if our in
our continuous delivery pipeline so the
second thing is experiment management
and that's a bit bigger thing than just
data versioning so we need to address a
couple things here so the first thing
it's Rocking
so we need to track experiments it's
difficult to track because we need to
store all the metrics all the models
sometimes we need to store some
immediate layers of the models and it's
also difficult to reproduce the results
and there are some custom mo platforms
but obviously there is no Holy Grail
so a net guru is Polly action and I'm
also
and Paulie action is the framework which
runs on top of kubernetes to manage
experiment cycle it's similar to cube
flow there are just some detail
differences but based but basically
there are those to our competitors and
we also introduced ml flow which is more
lightweight version of experimentation
system and I will dig more here into a
more flow
so our flow has three main components
the first one is tracking the second one
is projects and the third one is models
so the tracking tracking we have a goal
to store all the information about the
training so hyper parameters parameters
after the after I poke for example if we
needed some snapshots of models also the
matrix so we can later or even during
the training connect to the tensor board
and draw for example learning curves ml
for projects is basically interface for
deploying machine learning models from
different frameworks so it's basically
abstraction for a machine learning model
and Emma for models is the way of
storing the model so let's look at the
mobile tracking first so the whole of a
whole idea of mammal for tracking
component is that we can have our code
in completely different environments so
Jupiter notebooks some local apps cloud
jobs and we can connect and all flow
tracking to all of them and then we have
ml flow UI that we can see for example a
kind of leaderboard between models how
they perform and we have also API to to
access the details of our experiments
from ml flow UI which can be hosted on
premise it can be hosted on data breaks
or
actually yes so key components of animal
tracking so the first one is parameters
parameters is the way to store things
that we have some keys and values so for
example hyper parameters of training the
second component of ML flow is metrics
so things like accuracy precision recall
and so on
we have also artifacts that for example
model snapshots and we have also version
of commit from get and source which is
basically code base and here there is
example how how easy it's actually to
inject ml flow into the training code on
the scikit-learn
so first we need to start with with
clause which is context manager in
Python and when you execute that
statement the new run of some experiment
starts so it might be if you run it
twice there are just two different runs
because basically in my flow aggregates
experiments first an experiment has one
too many relation with runs so you can
set experiment name on a flow and also
you can set some run ID but there are
some defaults generated but basically
with when you get into that Swift clause
you just start the new run which is
connected one-to-many to your experiment
then you have standard scikit-learn code
for fitting some data and instead of
using those prints which are just going
to STD out you can lock parameters here
with Emma flow and you can lock matrix
with Emma flow and those metrics and
those parameters goes to the ever so if
you run Emma for locally there is ml
rands file where all of those are stored
typically on in iam files
but it also might be connected to data
brakes or just some cloud bucket the
other thing is ml products which is
interface for NFL 4 ml model for machine
learning model specification so another
project consists of code configuration
of that code and the data version that
it should run and it might be executed
wherever you want so ml project is a
convention to describe the code and it's
the ml file and with ml project usual we
have also that con diam which describes
your environment but you might also have
docker here so it's even better if you
have docker and it's easier to reproduce
and here are example files of M of ml
project and and condom so in ml project
you have entry point called main and the
entry points is something that you can
call with ml ml flow client interface
and execute on some remove machine so it
basically shows what comment is it's R a
lot that machine with what what
parameters that this entry point have
and what comment is run here and the
last thing is away from models so the
format storing data so we might have
different machine learning models from
different frameworks from tensorflow
with PP format from scikit-learn which
are usually saved to be cool and they
should be run on completely different
environments so for example some just
the karai's environment on your own
premise machine or on spark or some
cloud service
so whatever flow does it defines the
format for generic format for model
storage so basically it's one Yama file
which has two two entry points which are
important
the first one is describing the model so
it's the version of environment which
was used to run the model and the other
one is Python function which can be
executed in any Python environment and
it's it tells how to load the model so
you have that Yama file plus the binary
file of the model and it's everything
you need to deploy with ml flow to the
to some one premise machine or to the
cloud providers which are currently
supported by mo flow like data bricks or
Google Cloud or AWS yeah so summing up
archiving forever disability is not
really easy but we have already a lot of
frameworks to do that and it's actually
good first step because once you have a
lot of code a lot of motion and code
base it's not so easy to introduce the
tools but if you just start with from
the beginning with things like ml flow
they're quite easy to inject it's not
much overhead and then it's much easier
for you to reproduce the code and to not
have those moments then you deleted
something and and you need after for
example one year
run run it again so there are some
alternatives to another poly action and
an killed of course so the cube flow is
the one of them or the divorcee yeah and
I encourage you to try them out and
choose the best that's its suits your
problem so thank you very much
think about those questions to our
speaker any question about tools there's
light so I couldn't see that hi I also
think that this is a huge issue in data
science so imagine that we train a model
locally and you've said that ml flow
saves is to a file is there anywhere to
then reinitiate and like a framework
automatically sends the results to the
API and then I can after some point part
of being offline see the results or do I
have to do it manually yeah so basically
if you if you have or you can configure
at the beginning ml flow to send it to
some cloud for example and and if it's
configured for the cloud then it doesn't
store it locally at all but if it was
for example if you didn't have a no
internet connection and you just want it
to run on your device some experiments
then you have client comment line
interface to export that file to the
cloud Thanks
one more question
nope yeah this one the way which you
showed us requires an additional person
in your project for example ml oops
but why you don't recommend only use DBC
for us because you can create and
reproducible pipeline due to only two
commands device you're on and if you
want to reproduce you can use DBC Ripper
and that's all why you choose these
Hardaway okay so I'm not sure if it's
hard way what's yeah it's to assess on
your own
to be honest I haven't I don't know very
much dvc so maybe you're right and maybe
I should check it out what I heard about
the VC that there are some difficulties
with data we've data management in dvc
but it's just what I heard from from my
friends I didn't check it out you know
like on my own so maybe I should try it
out okay thank you so much thanks
[Applause]